good morning Hank it's Tuesday I had
oral surgery yesterday so I'm in a lot
of pain but I'm also on a lot of pain
medications so I apologize if I slur my
words or if blood dribbles out of the
corner of my mouth or whatever but
anyway Hank today's video is like the
Buddhist path to enlightenment it comes
to you in eight parts so like later this
week there's going to be this big
meeting in New York City at which 193
world leaders will agree to some global
goals for humans to achieve by 2030 a
while back a similar meeting happened at
which world leaders agreed to the
Millennium Development Goals eight goals
to change the history of the world
forever and surprisingly enough it sort
of worked so Hank today I'm going to
look back at those eight goals and then
maybe on Friday you can look forward to
the new ones for us okay goal number one
between 1990 and 2015 cut in half the
proportion of people living in extreme
poverty and suffering from hunger that
doesn't seem possible to do in 25 years
except that we did it yes people so in
1990 about 1.9 billion people lived on
the equivalent of less than a dollar 25
per day now even after adjusting for
inflation etc that number is more than a
billion people smaller most of this is
due to huge decreases in poverty in
China and South Asia and South America
but the rate of poverty in sub-saharan
Africa has also fallen since 1990 as for
hunger we're probably going to miss that
goal of reducing it by 50% but just
barely in 1990 23 percent of the people
in the developing world were
undernourished today it's under 13% goal
number to achieve universal primary
education they weren't messing around
with these goals Hank well we're not
quite there but again the progress is
really impressive primary school
enrollment in the developing world is
over 90% and in the last 25 years the
global literacy rate among young people
has increased from 83 percent to 91
percent goal number three gender
equality okay so speaking of kids in
schools in South Asia in 1990 there were
75 girls in school for every 100 boys
and today there are 103 girls in school
for every 100 boys step it up boys
worldwide women now make up 41% of the
non agricultural workforce in 1990 it
was just 35 percent and there are more
women working in universities and
serving in Parliament's that said there
are still massive disparities between
men and women so hope that's a big focus
for the new round of global goals ok
goal number four reduced the childhood
mortality rate by 66 percent between
1990 and 2015 so as you can see in this
video I stole from the Gates Foundation
sorry Bill and Melinda a lot of kids
before the age of five around the world
in 1990 but in the last 25 years the
childhood mortality rate has dropped
dramatically just to cite one example
measles vaccinations have prevented
about 15 million child deaths in the
last 25 years unfortunately we're going
to miss that sixty-six percent target
reduction but even so global childhood
mortality has dropped by more than half
since 1990 goal number five reduced the
maternal mortality rate by seventy five
percent as you can see in this Gates
Foundation chart full videos in the
doobly-doo by the way there was very
little progress on this front until 2005
and then when worldwide investment in
maternal health increased maternal
mortality decreased dramatically goal
number six halt and begin to reverse the
spread of hiv/aids and the incidence of
malaria this has been a huge success
again the HIV death rate began to
decline when investment in HIV
prevention and treatment began to
increase and we see the same thing with
malaria where global does have decreased
about 20 percent since 2002 all number-7
ensure environmental sustainability
let's not pretend that this has gone
well goal number 8 develop a global
partnership for development I think I'm
gonna level with you I don't know the
meaning of a sentence that seeks to
develop a development overall though
Hank this has been a really good 25
years for humans you are much less
likely to be poor or hungry or
illiterate than you were in 1990 if
you're a girl you're more likely to go
to school and if you're a mother you're
less likely to die during childbirth or
to have to bury one of your kids and the
Millennium Development Goals had a lot
to do with this now they certainly
weren't the only factor that the
attention and investment that resulted
from the MDGs made a huge difference and
that's why it's so important for all of
us to pay attention to the new goals
Hank there are young people watching
this video who may be among the first
humans to see a world where extreme
poverty and hunger are rare Hank I hope
we can learn more about what the plan is
to get humans to that place when I see
you on Friday